my favorite business is in the entire
world are built on excess capacity what
that means is businesses that have
leftovers it's scraps that people give
away for free one man's trash is another
man's treasure it's businesses built
around those Concepts Uber is built on
the excess capacity of people who have
cars and other people who want
Transportation but there was no one
linking the two there's excess capacity
in people's homes where they have rooms
that are not being used and people who
are flying it and they want to use it
but there's so many businesses and
there's so much excess capacity and
waste in the economy that if you're a
smart entrepreneur one of the easiest
and most profitable business models
because your cost of goods is zero it's
other people's waste finding another
man's trash and turning it into treasure